كشفت القوى المدنيه الواقعه على الاتفاق
لطريق السودان عن تقديمها مقترحا تفصيليا
لوقف الاعمال العدائيه خلال فتره عيد
الفطر وقالت تلك التشكيله السياسيه انها
تواصلت مع قياده القوتين وان المبادرات
لقي الترحيبا مبدئيا من الطرفين وعشره
لانها تنكب على تدقيق بقيه التفاصيل املا
في احكام المقترح
وكانت قوى سياسيه بالسودان اطلقت على
نفسها اسم مبادره هي القوى الوطنيه قالت
انها حصلت على موافقه مبدئيه من قياده
القوات المسلحه وقياده قوات الدعم السريع
لوقف الاعمال العدائيه خلال ايام العيد
واضافت ان الموافقه المبدئيه جاءت مرفوقه
ببعض الملاحظات التي تسعى المبادره
لحلحلتها خلال الساعات القادمه
وقالت ان هذه توطئه لتقديم مبادره شامله
تهدف الى وقف شامل لاطلاق النار واتخاذ
الحوار سبيلا لمعالجه جميع القضايا
والخلافات وتوجد ضمن مبادره القوى الوطنيه
حركه العدل والمساواه وحركه جيش تحليل
السودان ورئيس السلطه الاقليميه السابق
التجاني السيسي اضافه الى عضو مجلس
السياده مالك عقار